ça date de
le mais il faut le garder pour que si
jamais
l'avocat tatitré des victimes du
terrorisme en France cette femme attire
la haine de la diadosphère malgré les
menaces l'avocate demeure en première
ligne au procès de la tentat de Nice
après avoir rassuré la défense des
victimes au procès de Mohamed Merah de
Charlie Hebdo et du Bataclan c'est très
très important que ces procès est à
retentissement auprès de l'opinion
publique pourquoi d'abord parce que
c'est une réponse au terroriste non on
va pas
céder non on va rester debout et on va
continuer à vivre de la même manière
parce que c'est notre mode de vie c'est
notre démocratie c'est notre État de
droit que nous devons défendre
il y a deux ou trois c'est bientôt la
reprise de l'audience il faudrait que je
reparte allez au revoir
depuis quatre mois maître Maktouf
représente les parents des victimes de
l'attentat de Nice objectif libérer la
parole des participes c'est très
important que les parties civils soient
les éléments qui sont présumés innocents
à ce jour mais c'est très important
qu'il les entendent
sur plus de 2000 parties civils
constitués au procès près de 300 ont
exprimé le souhait de témoigner certains
n'étaient présentes sur la Promenade des
Anglais le soir de l'attaque et ont été
blessés ou traumatisés d'autres qui ont
perdu un ou plusieurs proches parfois
une famille entière beaucoup de désarroi
beaucoup de tristesse
également des sentiments de peur et
d'une façon générale un très gros
mal-être
je veux garder ma dignité ma fierté mon
courage et j'ai une pensée profonde pour
toutes les victimes pour les enfants
je veux que l'on se rappelle de ce jour
mais pas avec de la rancœur
les parties civils témoignent pour dire
à la cour l'atrocité de ce qu'elles ont
vécu pour tourner une page ou rendre un
hommage aux disparu l'un des moments
forts du procès les victimes attendent
avant tout que soit établi la vérité
elle souhaite également pouvoir être
entendu reconnu dans leur souffrance
elles ont attendu ce procès elles savent
que ces procès parce qu'on l'a vu avec
le procès B13 peuvent apporter de la
reconnaissance 6 ans après l'attaque de
Nice certains rescapés parents de
victimes de la Promenade des Anglais
reste fragile pour ceux qui le
souhaitent des associations de victimes
accompagnent leur long parcours
judiciaire il faut prendre la vie d'une
team comme un pulse qui a explosé et le
procès à travers l'audition des
enquêteurs des experts des témoins va
permettre de répondre à un certain
nombre de questions et de venir recoller
les différents morceaux du puzz pour
envisager la suite avec plus de sérénité
plus d'apaisement ça n'efface rien ça ne
guérit pas mais ça permet de se tourner
vers l'avenir en ayant le sentiment de
cette déchargé de quelque chose et
d'avoir les clés pour affronter l'avenir
avec plus de sérénité
la vie de myrtille a volé en éclat à 9
ans ce soir du 14 juillet sur la
promenade des anglais elle a perdu sa
mère et sa meilleure amie
aujourd'hui l'adolescente est au lycée
difficile pour elle à la 15 ans de
prendre la parole dans la grande salle
d'audience pourtant myrtille a tenu à
témoigner j'ai pris ma décision de venir
témoigner il y a un mois et demi
peut-être et j'ai écrit mon témoignage
qu'il y a quelques semaines parce que
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
trouver quoi mettre à l'intérieur en
fait c'est très compliqué de comme agir
et pour moi c'est important de parler de
l'avenir parce que toute façon c'est le
plus important maintenant c'est de voir
ce qu'on aura dans le futur préparer son
témoignage avec son père et son avocate
elle m'a touché j'en avais larmes aux
yeux c'était bouleversant oui c'était
bouleversant
cet espoir de résilience au travers de
cet appel du futur c'était très émouvant
ils ont vu la mort de tellement près que
le voile de l'enfance c'est déchiré de
manière définitive et que aujourd'hui ce
sont des enfants qui vivent avec l'idée
de la mort qui est permanente et
quotidienne
jour J pour les partis civils c'est le
début des plaidoiries nous retrouvons
maître Maktouf elle vient tout juste de
plaider pour ses clients ce matin
un déroulement parfait
elle a concentré son argumentaire sur
l'islamisme en Tunisie pour elle le
terroriste comme les accusés n'est ni la
France ni la Tunisie
avec l'espoir d'avoir délivré un message
et ce message que je voulais délivrer à
la cour c'est celui de comprendre
le l'endoctrinement de ces accusés le
terreau qui a permis de les façonner le
protocole terroriste qui a été mis en
place
ce procès n'apportera pas aux victimes
toutes les réponses qu'elles attendaient
la recherche d'éventuelles failles dans
le dispositif de sécurité de ce soir du
14 juillet 2016 fait l'objet d'une
information judiciaire à Nice mais
celle-ci est au point mort